Death, large animals,
broken internet--
these are all very scary
to the average person.
But could another one
of our fears be silence?
Hey everyone, Laci
Green here for DNews.
Sometimes I'm sitting in my
apartment trying to write,
and, before too long,
I'll find myself
putting on a YouTube video,
or the TV, in the background.
And it's not as if I'm
actually listening to the TV.
I'm just hearing it.
It's not loud.
It's just softly droning
on in the background.
I guess, to me,
there's something
mildly uncomfortable
about sitting
too long in total quiet.
A six-year study done
on 580 undergrads
found that, hey, I'm not crazy.
This is a widespread phenomenon.
And although they
haven't confirmed it yet,
scientists suspect that
this discomfort in silence
might be something
that's learned.
Perhaps it's a product
of the media bombardment
that we're faced with
in day-to-day life.
Perhaps it's the
airplanes and helicopters,
and buses and cars,
air conditioners,
heating systems,
computers, refrigerators,
distant conversations.
At any given moment there
are 30 to 60 decibels
of sound humming away in
the background of life.
Just stop and listen.
You'll hear it, even
if you didn't even
realize it was there.
We're so used to
this unquiet, perhaps
we're even starting
to prefer it.
But according to
science and things,
this preference
might not be so good.
The International Journal
of Hygiene and Environmental
Health reports that this
ongoing low level background
noise could have negative
effects on long term cognitive
learning and unconscious
physiological processes.
The ability to memorize
and recall information
is disrupted by
background noise.
A study at the US Army
Engineer Research Center
found that the ideal sound
level for test taking
is 28 decibels, about
the same as a whisper.
The theory goes background
noise, even when it's
low level, subconsciously
averts energy and brain
power to process all that junk.
But total silence ain't
that great either.
In Minneapolis, you'll find
the world's quietest room,
an anechoic chamber
in which the noise
levels are negative 9 decimals.
I don't even know
how that's possible.
But apparently it
is, and it drives
people insane, like,
literally crazy.
They start hallucinating
and craving human flesh.
OK, maybe not the
human flesh part.
But definitely hallucinations.
You're sitting there alone
with just your thoughts
and the sound of your heartbeat.
And your brain
just can't take it.
So it starts making [BLEEP] up.
The longest someone has lasted
in this profound silence
is 45 minutes.
The brain, man, it's
so hard to satisfy.
Like, do you want noise or not?
Perhaps the solution
to our sound woes
is somewhere in between.
In the comments
below, I want to know,
do you guys put on background
noise when you're doing stuff?
Or do you prefer the quiet?
Thanks for watching DNews.
guys.
We'll be back again tomorrow.